Ruth is with us in Dallas hi Ruth how
are you hi Dave um thank you so much for
taking my call I'm better than I deserve
how about you better than I deserve
how can I help Wow well I'm read your
book Total Money Makeover so I should be
a millionaire by now I just really want
to know how can we start this baby step
program sorry I'm just keeping up those
monthly bills like rent utilities it's
just killing us we're behind on
everything we can't get current and I
know that that's the first thing we need
to do is get current no yeah so how much
how much is your car payments well we
just paid off um one car would you do
that if you're behind on everything
well we're behind on like um behind on
utilities while we burn on utilities and
pay off your car
we don't make very much money yeah but
why would you pay off your car and be
behind on your utilities you mean it
just you me just paying the payment paid
it out you didn't pay extra on no no no
no we did so one of them doesn't have a
paper how much is the other payment the
other one is actually paid for my bank
by my parents my husband worked for my
dad so $200 comes out of his paycheck to
pay my parents every month for that car
okay and what is your household income
it's about 40k okay and how much is your
rent 1050 that's not going to work
because your take-home pay is less than
$3,000 mm-hmm so your how your rent is
40% of your take-home pay right um
we're at about 30 about 3400 a month's
take-home yeah so 40,000 your take-home
right right a little bit giver hey okay
all right that was is what your income
was okay mm-hmm 40,000 is your take-home
then it's still your rinse 30% of your
take-home it's pretty tough all right so
are you guys trying to live on a plan
have you tried that
I've signed up for every dollar com
is your husband looking at it with you
he he's not had time yet he needs to he
needs to make time he needs to make time
his wife just called a guy on a radio in
front of 12 million people and said and
cried and said we're broke
so it's true it's time for him to make
time tonight turn off the television put
the kids to bed and open up every dollar
this is a crisis right the two of you
need to sit down and look at this you're
trying to carry this all by yourself and
he's not helping right yeah well he is
trying he's selling everything he can
he's selling me I'm talking about yeah
Harry any of the deceit the weight of
the decision the weight of who we pay
first and who we pay second because
here's the thing you've got thirty four
hundred dollars coming in you have
enough to pay food and lights you should
not be behind on your utilities food is
first lights and water second rent is
third by the time you do those three
things then you figure out everything
else after that you should not be behind
on any of those things they're the first
three things you pay and so what's
happening is is you're making decisions
of crisis to crisis to crisis to crisis
and jumping from one thing to another
and you're doing it all by yourself
emotionally here is what I'm talking
about
the two of you do get your every dollar
budget done tonight tonight before you
go to bed don't turn off the lights
until every dollar budgets done both of
you and then you're going to see the
start to turn around both of you making
these decisions together this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
Oh